make sure you guys hit the Subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and uh
make sure you guys hit the like button
if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with DC Comics actually it's
been a little while since we covered
anything from DC and in this instance
Damian Wayne also known as Batman's son
also known as Robin basically faces off
against the world and defeats some of
the deadliest people who actually fight
some of the deadliest people in
existence which is amazing this story is
ridiculously phenomenal so what this
does is it initially picks up with
Batman and the bat Family actually on
the hunt for Damien because he simply
just disappeared now this is one of the
things to know given how prodigious
Damian Wayne's training is both is part
of the League of Assassins due to the
fact that he was basically raised by
Talia al ghoul since Batman didn't know
that he had existed for just years on
end as well as the training that he
gained from Batman once Bruce Wayne
learned that Damien was alive and was
his son and then brought him in
basically as Robin when this kid wants
to disappear he will disappear like he
will vanish he knows exactly how to do
that stuff and we end up finding out
that what he's actually doing is
fighting in an underground cage match
against a guy by the name of king snake
now Kingston appearance here is both
important and unimportant at the same
time and the sense that if Robin or if
Damien can defeat King Snake the hope is
that he'll get some kind of Passage to
What's called the Lazarus tournament
which is basically Mortal Kombat in the
DC Universe but the other reason why
King Snake being here is kind of cool is
because Damien is intentionally fighting
this guy now one of the things to know
is that this story comes off the heels
of Tom King's run on Batman so Damien
trying to sneak into Gotham City even
though he was told not to do so by Bane
and with Bane having uh Alfred prisoner
that Bane basically told the bat family
if any of you enter the city of Gotham I
will kill Alfred Damien in his
recklessness defied that order he
actually got to the mansion but he was
allowed to get there and then once he
arrived Bane made him watch as Bane
killed Alfred and so Damien's basically
been haunted by this experience ever
since but in a lot of ways going after
king snake is basically a way to get
revenge on Bane because the entire base
is behind King snake's character is that
at some point in time he got to Santa
prisca and as a mercenary he committed
crimes against the government but also
slept with a woman at the prison which
basically means that Bane is the son of
King Snake but as a result of that it's
a way for Damien to like indirectly get
his revenge on Bane but once Damian
defeats this guy he ends up basically
leaving hoping that this will earn him
some kind of a passage to the Lazarus
tournament but along the way we end up
finding out that like Damien is
basically reading manga which I'm sure a
lot of fans of DC Comics are going to
love kind of a fun fact I'm getting back
into manga for the ver like actually not
even getting back into it I'm getting
into manga for the first time ever I'm
reading spy family which I've heard was
really really good but it's kind of cool
to see that Damien is like into the
whole manga scene I don't know if that
was a long-standing element of his
character or not but the other part of
this and probably one of the more
significant parts of this is that he's
kind of haunted by the ghost of Alfred
not literally it's not literally
Alfred's ghost who's hanging over him
it's really more of his guilty
conscience is really what it is the fact
that he's haunted by the fact that his
actions are what directly led to the
death of Alfred and so in a lot of ways
it's his subconscious mind speaking his
concerns to him that his rational mind
is trying to Simply ignore trying not to
focus on but ultimately because of his
actions in facing off against king snake
and defeating him he's basically granted
passage to the Lazarus tournament and in
doing so once he gets to this tournament
itself it happens on Lazarus Island now
the funny thing about this is there's
only maybe a couple people right off the
bat who seem to indicate that they know
who Damien is the first one is of course
ravager who those of you guys who who
followed our coverage on uh Christopher
priest's Deathstroke run she's basically
the daughter of Deathstroke and she's
kind of being brought in and has been a
part of his team for quite some time uh
she's actually there for a mission of
her own but then you also have what's
essentially respawn now we don't know
anything about respawn this is a wholly
new character that's being introduced
here but there are a couple of things
that go on one of the first things that
happens is you have a woman who really
is a new character here being introduced
as mother their soul who if those are
guys who followed Mortal Kombat think of
her as like the Shang Tsung of this
story it's basically what she is right
the one that's essentially leading the
tournament now she has her own
motivation she has her own scheme for
why she's doing what she's doing but the
thing behind this is she says that there
are essentially Rules to This tournament
now of course Damien Wayne ever the
headstrong and kid it just goes and does
his own thing basically says like all
this chit chat's boring as hell are we
here to talk or are we here to fight and
so immediately he gets into a fight with
Flatline one of the other contestants
here and Flatline rips his heart out she
literally kills him in the first issue
Damian Wayne dies with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to it no
we're not gonna do that
but she rips his heart out in in like
the first issue and Damien Wayne dies
like just like that and it's kind of
it's kind of nuts right but of course he
ends up recovering due to the
capabilities of the Lazarus pits right
he's basically able to heal and then
he's restored and when that happens
there's a couple things to know one as
it's indicated here there does not seem
to to be any temporary insanity that
Damien Wayne undergoes due to exposure
to the Lazarus Pit so perhaps it's
something else that's basically leading
him to being healed I mean it's kind of
how they work right nobody can actually
die on the island now the reason why I
say that is that for those of you guys
who are unfamiliar with the Lazarus pits
these are basically a source of healing
that exists in the DC Universe on Earth
the people who are put into the Lazarus
pits can basically almost even be
resurrected from the dead depending on
how long they've been dead for but what
it does is when a person re-emerges from
the Lazarus pits more often than not
they usually go insane not always but
they usually experience just temporary
insanity as a result of the effects of
the Lazarus Pit and then once they're
able to kind of come back to normal they
just sort of go forward from there but
what ends up happening is ravager meets
with Damien and says okay there's a few
things you have to know here right
before you just flew off of the handle
and decided to fly a fight Flat Line
were ultimately killed that the rest of
the of the situation was explained to us
that the way this whole tournament plays
out is that you basically have three law
lives everybody has to die one time when
that happens then the actual Tournament
begins so in the time between basically
when they arrived on the island and when
everyone's died once which you can only
kill a person one time before the
official start of the tournament between
those moments it's more like a series of
sparring matches to kind of size up your
opponents and see what they're capable
of once you die a second time you come
back a third when you die the third time
your soul stays on the island and you
never come back to life so you
permanently stay dead now again we don't
know exactly why this is the case we'll
find out you know over over the the
robin run but it's a really really cool
element because following that when
Damien Wayne already being down one life
essentially nobody can kill him anymore
his death was exceedingly high profile
everybody saw it happen so people can't
really kill him I mean they could but
they'd be violating the rules if they
did and the indication here is that
violating the rules is a very severe
punishment and so as a result of that
Damien Wayne of course goes out and just
starts attacking all these different
people he killed was a whole bunch of
them kind of putting on his powers for
display and really letting people know
what it is that he's capable of but
beyond that you have ravager who
basically says okay with all these
people here there's a few that you need
to worry about right the first one you
need to worry about is basically respawn
like she says he's new then he's a piece
of work that his moves are chaotic and
they're undisciplined but he's
exceedingly dangerous so in a lot of
ways respawn is very similar to Damian
Wayne in the early days of Damien's
comic book appearances before he learned
finesse from Batman the next one is XXL
right who basically has an Entourage
that you know cheers this guy on which
seems to kind of piss everybody off but
beyond that he seems to have super
strength of course you have plotline and
will actually learn a lot more about her
relatively soon and then you have Black
Swan who's kind of like a ballerina
right she you know death is her is her
art as is essentially described but what
ravager says is the biggest person and
the most dangerous person that Damien
has to worry about is Conor Hawk now we
don't know exactly what's going on with
Conor Hawk's character what we know is
that for the most part when it came to
counter Hawk um before the events of
really like new 52 and DC rebirth and
all that kind of stuff that Connor Hawk
is the son of Oliver Queen and that his
origin to you know the the degree to
which we will get it over the course of
this particular video seems to kind of
fall in line relatively close to the
original origin that he had back when he
first appeared in DC Comics but the
thing about this is Connor Hawk is a he
has a huge following for people who love
Green Arrow and so I imagine for those
fans who are reading this story and it's
like Conor Hawk is a legitimate threat
and you need to be worried about him
dude like a lot of those fans are
probably just like yes like Conor Hawk
is legit the other caveat to this though
and what's so interesting about this is
that Connor Hawk is working with the
League of Assassins and so it's kind of
interesting to see why it is that these
guys are all kind of working in unison
it was really more the League of Shadows
than anything else but it's basically
that the League of Shadows basically
brought him now here's one of the things
that I want to explain here so in DC
Comics you have the League of Assassins
then you have the League of Shadows and
then you have the Lazarus League or the
Lazarus tournament whatever that is
right the league of Lazarus if you want
to call it that originally it was the
League of Assassins and that's all you
had you had Rosal ghoul his League of
Assassins and they were just the ninjas
that would face off against Batman every
so often the way this worked in DC
Comics is that because of the popularity
of the League of Shadows and the
Christopher Nolan Batman movies The
League of Shadows was rolled into DC
Comics and so the League of Shadows are
led by Lady Shiva and they're basically
a splinter group that broke off of the
League of Assassins for the league of
Lazarus if you want to call that the
Lazarus League they're also a splinter
group but this is when they're being
introduced and we don't really know
anything about them yet so over the
course of this we'll basically learn
about the the Lazarus league league
advisors we'll learn about Lazarus we'll
just call it that it just makes things
easier if we refer to it that way but
one of the things that happens and it's
really kind of counter Hawk's abilities
being put on display this guy is fast I
mean he is fast he's accurate and he is
ridiculously deadly so he doesn't feel
like The Offspring of Oliver Queen he
feels like like Damien 2.0 in a lot of
ways is what he feels like but at the
end of the day what you have is this
kind of continued tour from ravager who
takes Damien Wayne basically to the uh
to the barracks right to where they all
crash at and she's like this is where
you sleep now no one can attack anyone
else here this is the one place where
everything is a safe haven right so
nobody can try to kill you or anything
along those lines but the cool thing
about this is that what you end up
having is this moment where Flatline and
Damian Wayne just kind of talk to each
other for a little bit because
flatline's the one who killed him so at
the very least there's a bit of
curiosity between the two and in fact
they have this kind of moment where they
basically go to explore the island as
any young kids would do and they
discovered this enormous Lazarus Pit
that sits at the heart of the island and
there's some Cloak and Dagger discussion
from like Mother's soul but we don't
really know the ins and outs of it right
it's saying things like it's still too
unstable we need to feed it more if we
want to get the results we're looking
for Mother's Soul it's just those Cloak
and Dagger discussions right we don't
really know the significance of it or or
any of that where we simply just know
this whole thing kind of seems to be
their whole stick right this whole
Lazarus Pit is their whole thing again
we don't know the specifics of that but
the cool thing about that is you have
this moment where basically Damien Wayne
goes to leave and is ultimately taken by
surprise by ravager and that's one of
the things where ravager is like okay
look I get that you're you're
exceedingly capable you're a great
fighter and nobody you know anybody
would be stupid to say that's not the
case right you're clearly one of the
best fighters in the world but you're
also headstrong and you're reckless and
I can teach you a few things but Damien
Wayne really looks largely at the
fighting capabilities of ravager and
it's just kind of like you're not on my
level right like you're just not where
I'm at and so I'm just not too worried
about you there's nothing you can really
teach me now that's the case when it
comes to Damien because the response of
ravager is no yes I can right like you
need to come with me you need to learn
what it is that I have to teach and what
she says is that this is your you know
you with when it came to like the League
of Assassins and when when it came to
Batman you were taught how to fight you
were taught stealth you were taught
guile you were taught all those things
what you were never taught is how to
make friends and so literally like how
to have fun is what you're gonna learn
because she takes him to a part of the
island where despite the fact that all
these people are basically supposed to
fight to the death that they're all like
playing video games and like partying
and all that kind of stuff now one of
the first rules that was set down by
mother soul is that there is no
fraternization here because that
fraternization will actually lead to
Fighters being unable or unwilling to
fight each other to the death right I
mean this tournament's going on like
once every 100 years so it's not like a
brand new thing that just launched it's
been going on for a while but one of the
funny things here is that as soon as as
soon as Damian Wayne shows up you know
XXL is like who brought the narc right
and like everybody else like they just
they're not really taking to him and a
lot of you guys who were fans of Damian
Wayne you know is kind of his thing to
just sort of be a dick nobody likes a
guy who's a dick so that's why like
people just don't really don't really
seem to be that interested in him but
what they do respect is what any young
person respects shows of bravado right
like you know kind of thumping their
chest a little bit that sort of gorilla
chest beating that kind of goes on that
sort of thing they can sort of respect
that just given their own natures and
what they're about so while he goes
around and tries to make friends but
everybody kind of blows him off that one
of the things that happens that he takes
these these little daggers and he puts
his hand on the table and then he throws
the daggers down and they all land in
between his fingers at the exact same
time and just that display of accuracy
just blows everyone's mind they're just
like holy cow like all right man this
kid's all right dude like this kid's got
it because I'm initially they thought
that he was all show that there was
nothing to him but showing off that kind
of display of just accuracy and
capability people are like okay the
problem with this is that Damien Wayne
lives under the shadow of Batman so the
longer they talk to Damien Wayne the
more they all start telling their
stories about how they all got beat up
by Batman and that's what it turns into
it turns into this kind of outward
display of like hey Damien you're cool
but like your dad's cooler and so
ultimately while they're all telling
their stories and hanging out Damien
just basically walks away and then he
ends up coming across Connor Hawk and as
the two of them start talking they
actually kind of share this bit of a of
a connection between each other in the
sense that their relationships to their
father are very very similar that while
Bruce Wayne didn't necessarily abandon
Damien Wayne it was more that Bruce
Wayne just didn't even know that Damien
existed that Conor's father Oliver Queen
did basically abandon him right that
Oliver Queen learned that his wife Sarah
Sasha that she was pregnant with his son
and he held him like once and then
walked away and that was basically it
right so it was a lot of those instances
where they are just kind of coming to
grips with their relationships to their
dad now again the DC rebirth origin of
Conor Hawk has not been fully fleshed
out yet it will be but the reason why
that's important is because we don't
know if the origin of Conor Hawk as it
exists now is the same origin as before
the events of DC rebirth if it's the new
52 or whatever because remember with
everything going on in DC Comics right
now dark crisis and all that kind of
stuff the reconciliation of the pre-new
52 universe and the existing New 52
universe that's all being reshuffled yet
again so you're likely going to start
seeing people getting new Origins that
are going to be updated post dark crisis
whatever this is right if they decide to
go that route I'm not entirely sure they
will but characters like Hunter Hawk are
a little bit murky in the DC landscape
but the thing about this is that while
Conor is told by the league of uh the
League of Shadows do not associate with
people here and certainly not with him
that because he owes them some kind of a
debt in the sense that they basically
saved him and they took care of him when
seemingly nobody else would again we
don't really know the ins and outs of
that that it leads to Connor Hawk being
told by the League of Shadows kill him
right and they're not one like they're
not supposed to be fighting at night and
two they're not supposed to keep on
fighting after one person has already
died but the result of this is that
Connor Hawk does it anyway because
there's no one here to tell him no
there's no one here from Lazarus to like
oversee what's going on and to tell him
you're not supposed to do that and so
ultimately Conor goes after Damien and
where Damien faces off against Conor and
is kinda able to hold his own
momentarily in the end Conor's just too
fast and he's too capable he gets the
upper hand on Damien and then literally
cracks his back and then throws him over
the uh throws him over the cliff which
is a really really cool moment because
it's kind of like Damian Wayne sort of
getting his own Bane moment to a degree
but when he's thrown over the cliff
instead of being dashed on the Rocks
below and dying he's basically whisked
away and we end up finding out that he's
taken to the location of Ra's al ghoul
that the reality here is that him being
brought to Raaz al Ghul was done by
virtue of his pet Goliath now goliath
was like the pet of Damian Wayne and in
all honesty Golia I kind of took a back
seat after a little while we didn't
really know exactly where he went to but
it's cool to see that like the two of
them were reunited right because like
him and Goliath were like best friends
and Goliath loves Damien Wayne so it's
cool to see that Goliath is still kind
of keeping an eye out for you know his
master to a degree I guess you could
really call it that but it's just kind
of this really really cute moment
because it's one of those instances
where you kind of get a momentary
reprieve where you cut through all of
like the super seriousness of Damian
Wayne and you remember like he's still a
little kid right like he is in a lot of
ways just still a kid and that's one of
the best elements about Damien when DC
Comics when he's written right in this
instance Joshua Williamson is the one
that's writing it it's one of those
great little moments because you get to
see like the child part of Damian Wayne
it's why I loved the super Sun's comic
so much which by the way we might start
covering some Teen Titans stuff right
because the Teen Titans Comics are just
good old fun but the thing about this is
that Damien Wayne basically meeting with
Raz Al ghoul the question that he asked
is like where have you been all this
time now the answer to this question
actually comes from another comic called
Batman and The Outsider and it's
actually kind of a follow-up to a plot
point that was made in the main Batman
comics which was the basis behind the
formation of the League of Shadows that
Raz Al ghoul had come to the belief that
Humanity was ultimately going to destroy
the world and so what Raz al Ghul wanted
to do was form a group called The League
of Shadows as a splinter group of the
League of Assassins that would basically
help him achieve world domination Lady
Shiva was put in charge of it and then
Lady Shiva turned against him and so in
Batman and The Outsiders it was
basically Batman and orphan and like
black lightning and all that kind of
stuff and they all basically teamed up
against Raz al Ghul and they ultimately
defeated him um we might cover that at
some point it was a 17 issue run it's
not overly lengthy it really kind of
feels like a maxi series plus a few more
issues but it's a pretty cool story it's
it's it's certainly worth a read I think
it's pretty solid but uh that's
ultimately where Raz Al ghoul has been
ever since just kind of biting his time
preparing for this war that he's going
to launch which is actually called
Shadow war and that's the story arc that
I think just recently finished in the
Batman comics so really a Batman Robin
and Deathstroke crossover but the thing
about this is that with that kind of
information being given to Damien Damien
comes to the belief that Rosal ghoul is
the one that basically initiated this
whole tournament he's the one that
brought Damien here and all that kind of
stuff but the response to razakhul is
again he's just kind of laying low for
the moment and the reason why he comes
to this place this island is because it
allows him to look out into the stars
and that provides a kind of background
motivation for why things unfolded in
the uh Batman and The Outsider story The
farazov Ghoul it's not world domination
just for the sake of world domination
that he genuinely cherishes the world
that he genuinely values the world in
which they live and seeing Humanity
destroy it through a variety of
different things the creating the League
of Shadows and trying to conquer the
world was his way of trying to save it
from like the stupidity of humanity and
so it's one of those things where he's
just kind of been in the background ever
since but what's bigger than that is he
tells Damien like like you have so much
turmoil right your heart is full of Rage
way too much for a child that's so young
what you need is to learn to calm your
heart and what you need is to learn how
to truly fight at somebody not someone
who fights not someone who takes every
single attack and uses it to their
advantage right attacks on every single
opportunity that's what you were trained
and that's what you were initially
taught but what Batman's been trying to
teach you and what I want to teach you
here is just because you can strike at a
certain moment doesn't mean you need to
strike at a certain moment you need to
learn the art of how to attack properly
and so that's kind of what he teaches
them right he teaches him not really any
particular fighting style but more how
to take his fighting style to the next
level I mean he does teach him some
enhanced fighting techniques and it's
kind of cool to watch Goliath training
alongside them that's pretty awesome
I absolutely love that moment but
ultimately he ends up leaving the
purview of Raz Al ghoul and travels to
Corto Maltese and this is one of the
coolest moments in the story because
when he gets there there's a couple
things that we learned that had happened
while he had been gone the first is that
ravager have been killed by respawn so
she's already down one life so when she
died basically she was resurrected but
that leads to the official start of the
tournament and so really it's the
tournament's gonna start with or without
Damien but he better get there in time
otherwise he automatically forfeits so
the thing about this is that once
Damian's at Corto Maltese what he's
looking for is this book that belongs to
the priests of Lazarus which seemingly
contains the plans of what it is that
Mother's soul is looking to do with this
tournament in the first place because at
the end of the day as much as he wants
to win this tournament is also what
Casey wants to crack what's going on
with this whole thing this tournament
mother's soul and all that kind of stuff
but as he's there ultimately we end up
finding out that Winnie been taken out
by Conor Hawk and nobody knew where he
was that ravager had contacted Red Hood
and when she did Red Hood got a hold of
the rest of the bat family minus Batman
and they've all basically responded and
you get this amazing moment where they
all basically track him down and they
all start trying to apprehend him in
order to bring him in and of course
Damien overpowers the entirety of the
bat family with the exception of Batman
now this is one of the cooler moments
here and the reason why I say that is
that anybody who's a fan of Damian Wayne
will tell you yes dick Grayson's really
really cool dick Grayson's really really
awesome he was the original Robin right
he's always gonna hold a special place
in everybody's hearts that yes Tim Drake
is really awesome right he's a you know
every bit as smart as as Bruce Wayne is
and it's capable um that red hood is
like the Vigilante he's like what if
Batman met the Punisher and like that's
red hood you know that kind of a thing
but when it comes to just fighting
technique Damian Wayne is above them all
and it's awesome to see that right it's
awesome to see that kind of being
recognized here that Damien Wayne is the
best fighter out of every member of the
bat family and so the real kicker about
this is that ultimately where where
Damian Wayne ends up being caught up to
by Nightwing that unlike the other
members of the bat family who are trying
to like capture him and bring him in
that dick Grayson's just kind of like
you're trying to find your way and I
respect that I respect that you're
trying to find your way and you're
trying to do your thing you have a
mission here and this is a fight that
you need to fight on your own so what he
does is he presents him with one of his
batons he gives it to Damien and says
like on the Baton itself it says versus
the world that the reason why this
matters is when Dick Grayson first
struck out when he when he first became
Robin and then started doing his own
thing as Nightwing when he struck out on
his own then Alfred presented him with
this baton and saying like you can
conquer the world right it's you versus
the world and it was a ceremonial thing
that was given to to Dick Grayson Dick
Grayson is passing that on to Damian
Wayne the reason being is twofold the
first is because Damian Wayne is
currently the Robin in the back family
right you have other members of the bat
family but in terms of who's occupying
the role of Robin That's Damian Wayne a
role that was once occupied by Dick
Grayson but the other part of this is
that during the instance when you
basically had Bruce Wayne who was
believed to have been dead following me
the events of final crisis when he was
actually time displaced by Darkseid and
his Omega sanction that Dick Grayson
temporarily became Batman and Tim Drake
became Robin that means they share a
bond that nobody else has right there's
no one else out there in the bat family
that has the same kind of bond with
Damien that Nightwing does and so that's
the other reason why Dick Grayson is
giving to him is quite literally passing
on the mantle which is kind of has
unofficially been done in DC Comics
several times over the years but it's a
very ceremonial moment and a very
personal moment that's going on here and
so ultimately Damian Wayne just kind of
breaks down in front of Nightwing and it
was like I I was there I saw Alfred die
and it's the first time that we've
actually seen Damian Wayne break down
like this since the death of Alfred he's
kept that barrier up I kept that wall up
kept that part of himself just hidden
away from everyone else and has been
trying to come to grips with it in his
own way but the truth about about
Nightwing is he says I know and that's
when when Damien's just like you know
death has been a part of my life since I
was born but with Alfred I did didn't
get it until I heard the snap Damien has
always killed people right he did that
when he was part of the League of
Assassins he stopped doing that when he
was being trained by Batman but but
death is not an uncommon thing to him
the death of Alfred was the first time
he experienced the death of someone he
loved the death of someone he genuinely
cared about and that's when he truly
realized the impact of death because
Alfred's not there it's not as though
Alfred just sprung back up and was like
man we almost escaped you know we almost
we almost bit the bullet good thing that
it was that happened and kept me from
dying that like Alfred's dead and gone
and is Damien coming to grips with the
reality of what it truly means to lose
someone you love and so ultimately
that's when Nightwing right you know
Nightwing says you know how many times I
ran away from home from Bruce and Alfred
more than I can count for a long time I
was Batman's sidekick or the leader of
the Titans it took a bit for me to
figure out who I was away from that and
when Damien asks why are you telling me
this the response of Dick Grayson is Tim
Drake right Stephanie Brown Jason Todd
we're all Robins to Bruce first but you
were my first Robin not only that you
are Bruce Wayne's son you're his
biological son the rest of us we're all
just adopted right but like everybody
else we were Robins for Bruce Wayne
first right you were my first Robin but
the statement of Dick Grayson here is
don't run right like this is your story
this is you figuring out who you are
what you're about you have to embrace
this so go forward and fight in this
tournament do your absolute best and and
wherever it takes you takes you and so
following that once he arrives back to
the tournament itself the whole thing
begins and mother Soul says like this is
our time right it's our moment to fight
let the tournament begin and so what you
get is you get round one right Robin
versus blue strike and of course Robin
overpowers this guy quite readily right
Damien takes this guy out with a
quickness and literally everybody else
gets taken out very very fast I mean
like for the most part the the the herd
is thinned very quickly right like round
two is is Robin versus tangu Robin takes
that guy out with a quickness right like
these are kind of ancillary characters
that don't really matter and are
defeated incredibly fast and it's almost
in a lot of ways Damian Wayne finding
this kind of perfect balance between
everything that Batman had been teaching
him and everything he learned is part of
the League of Assassins initially he is
kind of stepping into his own right you
can almost kind of hear the Montage
Music as all this goes on it's a cool
thing but of course one of the other
parts of this is that Flatline rips out
the heart of her opponent and that's
when Damien Wayne who's observing all
these people fighting and their fighting
styles comes to the realization that she
only really seems to have one move which
is just ripping a person's heart out
that really seems to be it but looking
at everything else right XXL comes out
on top drenched comes out on top ravager
defeats her opponent right like Connor
Hawk takes his guy out they all kind of
come out on top they do their own thing
that Black Swan defeats her opponent as
well so they kind of know who's gonna be
fighting next and so what we end up
doing here is going into round three
right round one was when they first got
on the island round two was really like
this first part of the tournament and
then round three is now everybody else
right the ones who are basically left
over and that's when the pairings are
revealed right they're right off the bat
that what you have is you've got Robin
versus respawn you've got Hawk versus
XXL and you've got Flatline versus
drenched and when the fight breaks out
right it's like everybody fight face off
against your opponent right when the
fight breaks out Robin going after uh
respawn is really more of a distraction
than anything else that in this instance
Robin basically runs right he goes and
he leaps and respawn of course launches
his his chain weapon which hits Robin
but it basically knocks him down but it
wasn't really Robin's intention right as
soon as he goes taking off running he
just books right he just immediately
takes off and where respawn looks at
what Robin is doing and he was like why
are you running away the response of
Robin is I'm not running away this was
all part of my plan right to basically
move in such a manner to where you would
attack me and I could feign being hit by
your attack fly into mother's Soul knock
the book out of her hands and then take
it and literally run off with it which
is what he's doing here and as he's
going through what he says is that he
has been studying Lazarus tattoos the
language itself and learning how to read
it and he says there's something hidden
within the pits and it's more important
than what she's planning he says I think
I know who mother's Soul really is the
problem is that that's impossible
whoever mother's soul is there's no
conceivable way she can be alive so
here's what I want to know what are your
theories on who mother soul is in this
story but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later
peace